this is what prepared looks like for the
NHS protective suits results exchanged
through glass can you Craig Dylan spent
12 hours in quarantine it's in Thomas's
Hospital the subject of multiple blood
tests and swabs he became ill while
flying back from Taiwan via connecting
flight through China there was the glass
because we were like sealed in and had
like intercom that they were talking
through but of course like they're all
in these like masks so they can't really
it's hard so I can you I could hardly
really understand what they were saying
because they're like sealed in these
suits so yeah there was they were trying
to explain and they had they would like
make notes on the paper and then
sellotape them to the glass of the team
outside could like copy the notes down
well Airport health checks in China
picked up that Creek at a high
temperature at Heathrow he was waived
straight through I landed at Heathrow
and met all of my friends and went into
work and went to like Starbucks and
stuff like that you know there should
have been something more Heathrow in
Scotland and Northern Ireland a number
of people are being tested for the
coronavirus as a precaution this after
traveling from the Chinese city of
whoo-hah at least two of those tested in
Scotland were diagnosed with influenza
none have so far tested positive for the
corona virus before news emerged of
suspected cases Scotland's Force
Minister Nicola Sturgeon addressed the
developing situation well I can share
the chamber that together with Health
Protection Scotland we are very closely
monitoring what is a rapidly evolving
situation I should say that the risk to
the public here in Scotland and indeed
the UK is currently classified as law
but obviously that is kept under review
in the Commons the UK health secretary
Matt Hancock set out similar leaders to
reassure while there is an increased
likelihood that cases may arise in this
country we are well prepared and well
equipped to deal with them over the last
two weeks public health England has been
in touch with German researchers to
develop a diagnostic test to identify
the new strain of disease and as a
precaution the NHS is
for the worst with clinicians being
advised on detection and infection
control but public health expert
professor John Ashton isn't convinced
we're as prepared as we've been in the
past something that I'm worried about
now are the weak connections often
between the Public Health Service in
local governments as it is and the
clinical services in the NHS which have
been weakened since 2013 following that
reorganisation in Newcastle's chinatown
for those who have relatives in Wuhan it
is a worrying time although we are going
to celebrate they're trying to do you at
this coming Sunday or the people got the
mood to servery but we hope everything
will be all right over there omits
preparations to celebrate the Lunar New
Year it's impossible to escape dark
headlines of a growing crisis as around
the world efforts continue urgently to
limit its spread